guau
vamos a hacer
un juicio de valor
es una pregunta y no la van a responder
se van a quedar con ella
sean lo más críticos posibles y no se
reserven lo que se les venga la mente
eso eso piensa en ti que se con ello
cuando me ven que miran
mi nombre es miguel vicente y
a día de hoy prefiero practicar las
personas desde un niño
sucede que había un niño que cuando
tenía 11 años
tiene el cuerpo de un niño de 6
era el más bajito del salón el primero
de la fila al quemaban chaparrito el
enano todos ubicamos a uno no estamos
acordamos de uno
este niño
todos los días que iba a la escuela que
sufría de apodos ese momento sufría de
bullying no sabía que era vulnera
carrilla sufría de pues de acoso por su
apariencia física
era cansado para el salir al receso y
ella no ven o el chaparro ven llegar a
la tiendita
y no hay cansar la barra para poder
pedir algo entonces pues era incómodo
porque le daba vergüenza acercarse a la
barra y pues pedir algo porque estaba
muy alta
y así pasó la primaria pasó a la
secundaria
y lo mismo no nada de liderar
competencias deportivas nada de tener
éxito con las muchachas en secundaria
pues ya tienen sus gustos
el apodo la secundaria son más
ingeniosos como apodos recuerdo que le
decían elena hoy es elena y si o si es
echado porque median elena pues si soy
hombre hasta que un día se da cuenta que
tiene elena porque era el enano
y dijo bueno volviendo un secundaria
si pasó la secundaria sobreviviendo con
esa adversidad que posee la carrilla la
carrilla de saná no los papas dicen acá
restas carrillo
entre la universidad o la prepa es lo
mismo entre la universidad
y lo mismo no solamente que en la
universidad ya no presente recurrente
los apodos ahí ya la gente los jóvenes
que en un criterio instinto no hay esa
persona se dio cuenta que tenía una
habilidad una habilidad que en la prepa
no le importancia
en la prepa esta persona era presidenta
socia de alumnos
era consejero universitario era líder
estudiantil era muy inteligente
pero no le daba importancia porque en la
prepa imagínense ser un tipo chaparrito
gordito que jugaba lluvia
ya para tener pues era como que el
blanco perfecto no
bueno pues en la universidad ser tener o
sea inteligente ya es un poco más pues
más redituable porque porque los
maestros ya te te te voltean a ver las
personas que buscan porque es
inteligente y porque ocupan tu ayuda
entonces se propuso una meta ser el más
listo de
de la clase pues ya tenía por cien se
presentó de ciudad alumnos consejo
universitario llegó a la universidad y
lo mismo me siento hacia el alumno es
que universitario pecó perfecto hijo
perfecto para los papás
fue en universidad en que se encontró en
una de sus materias de derechos humanos
que estudiaba derecho
que lo que había padecido él
no era más que sinónimo de una cultura
una cultura que pareciera que es
correcta te da risa yo pues todos se
rieron aquí
pero él había aparecido de bullying él
había aparecido de acoso él había
padecido
de que sus derechos mínimos ustedes
fueron privados y se dio cuenta en esta
materia ya que la conocimos la
profundidad que él no era el único
que también había personas que eran pues
homosexuales pero que toda su vida hayan
vivido bien llega la universidad con ese
problema de bullying acoso había
personas obesas que llegan a una
universidad con ese problema de bullying
y de acoso y que todo el mundo los
miraba normales porque la carrilla
normal
en lo laboral por ejemplo
es normal que veamos que cuando se
solicitan trabajo una persona solamente
tiene el currículum pitt o experiencia
laboral
pero es lo mismo por una persona por
ejemplo que está en silla de ruedas
se supone que el estado supone que tiene
que brindar t empleos dignos y bien
remunerados a todos los mexicanos
tiene que crear esas alianzas con las
empresas ya saben para que haya empleos
dignos y bien remunerados para todos los
mexicanos mexicanos de primera o
mexicana una segunda tanto derecho tiene
es el que está este lado de un trabajo
digno como el que tiene en la caja
no hay derechos para unos o derechos
para otros
en lo civil
pues una persona pues tiene derecho a
casarse no
pero si te gusta un hombre no te puedes
casar
por qué pues porque no por qué por qué
no
quien te están privando de un derecho
quien tiene derecho a privar de un
derecho como el matrimonio
en lo social
pues una persona de estatura promedio
puede ir una oficina del gobierno la
ventanilla pagar recibos del agua lo que
sea no o un restaurante y en la barra y
pedir un agua limón un tequila y el que
estamos de tequila
pero es lo mismo para una persona de
talla baja los que llevamos granitos que
todos pensamos que son solamente para la
diversión
o pensamos que no existen
saben ustedes el número de personas que
trabaja que existe en el país
su estadística muy grande que sólo deja
de tarea para que hagan un poco de
conciencia
a lo que voy es que
estas personas por toda su vida junto
con él muchachos del chaparrito que
llegó a la universidad con complejos
toda su vida han estado privados de sus
derechos elementales de los derechos más
simples de sus garantías individuales
están privado que se puedan casar se han
privado que tengan acceso a una
educación es tan privado
que siquiera vayan a hacer un trámite a
gobierno tengan todas las condiciones
para hacerlo
no han podido hacerlo porque porque
todavía en méxico existen derechos para
unos
y derechos para otros en la práctica en
la teoría no en la teoría todos los
derechos son para todas las personas
estas personas que acabo de mencionar
estos grupos al igual que las personas
de comunidades indígenas al igual quiero
discapacitados
al igual que los herejes forman parte de
un grupo selecto de un grupo selecto que
la corte interamericana derechos humanos
que es la máxima del ges humanos en el
mundo
ha denominado como personas
en situaciones de vulnerabilidad o
grupos vulnerables
y están aquí entre ustedes seguramente
más como se identificó pues ustedes son
personas que han vivido toda su vida en
situación de vulnerabilidad por quien
creen pues porque tienen al lado
van a pegar nada más
pero es una realidad
es una realidad estas personas conviven
día a día entre nosotros en este salón
en nuestra familia
en nuestra escuela en nuestro grupo
sociales y no les prestamos atención
pensamos que no existen o pensamos que
pues son poquitas que son dos
en méxico ha habido muchos avances en
materia de derechos humanos
ha habido muchos avances y se ha
legislado para el promedio las leyes
están hechas para el promedio de la
gente pero son tantas las personas que
hoy en día sufren de algún tipo de
vulnerabilidad sus derechos que mucha
gente ha alzado la voz para que se
respeten sus derechos mínimos sus
derechos mínimos han luchado por algo
que no se debería de luchar porque
luchar por algo que es tuyo porque lucha
por algo que te está concediendo el
estado
había muertes de personas
por alzar la voz
en los años 50 imagínense hace dos
décadas tres décadas las mujeres ni
siquiera podían votar
las mujeres eran un grupo vulnerable hoy
en día imagínense que hay una elección a
quien sea por ciento municipal o de
presidente y digan ok estas elecciones
solamente vamos a decir los hombres
quien tiene las mujeres hoy es pero yo
tengo derecho no
las mujeres no pueden votar
pues esta es una realidad que no hace
más de dos generaciones sucedió incluso
te seguro que alguna de sus abuelitas no
votaron porque no podían porque no les
dejaba el estado
desde ese año a la fecha en cascada se
han venido desarrollando o se han venido
garantizando más derechos de más
personas han nacido nuevos grupos
vulnerables y los que ya existen
han garantizado sus derechos
hay gente que desde el país que nos
representa en la onu y firman tratados
firman acuerdos para que los derechos
más vanguardistas en materia de derechos
humanos sean para cada mexicano
pero pues en la práctica no es así
entonces para eso es necesario alzar la
voz parece necesario
que ese niño
diga lo que sintió
y que otras personas se identifiquen con
él
y que exijan lo que les pertenece que es
un derecho un derecho mínimo
este niño posiblemente saben que soy yo
hicieron cuenta
miguel vicente
soy licenciado en gastronomía y
licenciado en derecho
soy economía acabo de terminar no me
estoy en habitación pública soy
emprendedor tengo una consultoría
puesto que los que me decían estos
aparatos a nito pues ahí los vieron nada
más
cuando les dije que hicieran emiten un
juicio de valor
era para que se dieran cuenta de cómo
juzgamos a las personas sin conocerlas
es cierto que un título no te genera no
te hace más que nadie la verdad que uno
estudia por pues para aprender no no
para que le diga el maestro para que
leyendo en mi caso por no es así pero
guateques un juicio valor
de una persona solamente puede simple
hecho de verla
estás agregando lo estás discriminando
lo estás
estamos te cuenta que es una persona que
por su educación en tu casa o por por lo
que has convivido
no te das cuenta que la gente no se
juzga por la apariencia
el día de hoy
en este bloque detrás del miedo
quiero compartirles esta idea quiero
compartirles la idea de que las personas
que sufren de alguna discriminación
existen y que están entre nosotros
quiero que esta idea se la lleven a su
casa y la hagan propia
que no porque no sufre ningún tipo de
discapacidad o discriminación
no vean por los demás las personas que
son aparentemente normales o que tienen
una condición privilegiada sobre las
demás no es que tengan muchos
privilegios simplemente que tienen
privilegios sobre los demás muchas veces
son apáticas y la lucha por la defensa a
los derechos humanos no solamente le
corresponde a las personas que sufren
algún tipo de discapacidad o algún tipo
de acoso o algún tipo de lo que sea no
la lucha es de todos esta idea es para
que ustedes aprendan a convivir con este
tipo de personas y reconocer que existen
que se pongan en el lugar por ejemplo de
los discapacitados en el lugar no en su
espacio porque lo va a inspeccionar en
lugares azules en el lugar
que respete el mínimo mínimamente los
espacios y los espacios reservados para
que las personas con discapacidad
desarrollen sus actividades
y cuando volteé a ver una persona de
talla baja no le digan a mira el enanito
él nos dice él nos pidió no ser así
este niño que no hubiera dado seis
centímetros más alto seis centímetros
más alto me gusta ya no me vale pero en
algún momento en algún momento todos los
niños se lo digo porque su estudio de
caso estudié tesis todos los niños que
tienen condiciones talla baja o
condición estén o enfermedad que cuando
playas y no sino chaparritos
dentro de sus principales prioridades
son ser más altos ellos quieren ser más
altos ellos no quieren sufrir bullying
por sus compañeros porque son
chaparritos ellos no quieren ser el
primero en la fila todos piensan que
privilegia está en primera fila pero
novatos tp the shoppes
ellos quieren ser más alto y porque
quieren ser más altos porque no quieren
sufrir más discriminación por parte de
ustedes
es por ello que
esta idea creo que si todos lo adoptamos
si todos la agarramos como propia y lo
aplicamos como una comunidad
herramienta más hacia nuestras actitudes
personales y hacia nuestra manera de ver
la vida va a poder hacer de este mundo
un mundo más igualitario y un mundo más
incluyente donde podamos convivir como
sociedad todos
discriminación por sexo preocupación por
preferencia sexual
por condición física
sigo respetando que todas las personas
son diferentes en su actuar pero que
todas tienen el mismo derecho que
ustedes tienen cuando quieran criticar
una persona
porque se le cuestiona sus derechos
pregúntense sí
qué pasaría si ustedes les negaron ese
derecho
ponga en el lugar esa persona
la vida de una persona que ha sufrido
discriminación es muy complicada
ellos todos los días sufren una batalla
por salir adelante
y las personas que tienen una condición
distinta a ellos muchas veces no somos
sensibles con esa causa
muchas veces hacemos como que no existen
pasamos por un lado unas personas
muletas y nos ayudamos tenemos prisa
pasamos por una persona de apariencia
indígena y hacemos feo
no que lo voy a tocar
va a pegar algo
pasamos por un lado de una persona en
silla de ruedas que soltamos a vecinos
amigos la señora amir el señor
pero no hacemos nada
y no hacer nada que una barrera entre
unos y otros crea un muro invisible ese
muro se llama desigualdad y la
desigualdad
la cultivamos día al día cada uno de
nosotros
la cultivamos día a día con pensamientos
como que las mujeres no saben manejar y
los hombres son mejores para manejar los
índices
en un estudio
la cultivamos día a día pensando por
ejemplo en el caso de las mujeres que
pues las mujeres bonitas pues son
bonitas nada más no son inteligentes
las cultivamos día a día pensando que el
hincha para la escuela no puede ser ante
un equipo de fútbol digo los que
proyectan
o que no puede jugar basquetbol
ay beisbolistas y basquebolistas
campanitas qué
entonces el objetivo de esta charla en
esta materia de derechos humanos
y en este bloque es simplemente para
dejarles una semilla antes de que nos
vayamos y que no construyamos más
desigualdad en esta ciudad de que
podamos incluir dentro de nuestras
actividades diarias a personas que
que creemos que no necesitan o que no
existen las ideas que han escuchado este
día
pues son muy padres y van a cambiar el
mundo todas de ellas
pero solamente van a cambiar
el mundo si se hacen realidad
las ideas son de nosotros pero el poder
de hacer la realidad solamente es de
ustedes
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]